[Musica]
io ho dato questo titolo un pochino
giocoso al mio intervento perché vorrei
iniziare proprio dalle parole ostili per
poi concludere il mio percorso su un
altro tipo di parolo stili questa volta
con le giuste maiuscole ed è la storia
di un rehab rehab credo sia una parola
che tutti conoscete è una specie di
riabilitazione anche vedrete nel corso
delle mie diapositive perché io nasco
blast atrice ovviamente avendo studiato
tanto la lingua prima all'università poi
a dottorato e poi con questa mia
passione per i social network sono
sempre stata nella posizione di superare
in dialettica e in argomentazione i miei
avversari online per cui non avevo
nessun problema a trovare la parola
giusta quella che faceva più male quella
che puntava dritto alla debolezza della
persona di fronte perché in realtà tutti
voi lo sapete abbiamo tutti un tallone
d'achille da killer come dicono i miei
studenti che è uno dei loro ma l'afro
fism i preferiti e il tallone d'achille
a volte è molto facile da trovare altre
volte meno ma in ogni caso ogni persona
ha un punto debole anche quella che si
erge habla stato re e dalla quale non ti
aspetteresti che invece ha qualcosa da
nascondere
quindi bastare vediamo una grandissima
soddisfazione
è un po come la droga se voi pensate
in questa prospettiva all'andare online
e annichilire con le parole l'avversario
ecco è un po la sensazione di una
striscia di coca cioè qualcosa che è lì
per lì ti dà una grandissima agitazione
poi però quando spegni il computer ti
rimane una specie di forma di tristezza
di così il dow appunto e quindi a un
certo punto quando mi sono trovata io
dalla parte della persona bla stata in
particolare c'è stato un episodio di non
tantissimi anni fa in cui girò una mia
fotografia
anzi una fotografia di mia gamba
mentre partecipavo a una kermesse è una
famosa giornalista milanese fece lo
screenshot di questa foto lari condivise
sui social dicendo guardate qua che
cotechini e io ci rimasi malissimo anche
se in realtà nessuno sapeva parte mail
che erano i miei cotechini quindi non si
capiva questo era una vergogna molto
privata però lì per la prima volta mi
misi dalla prospettiva dell'altro cioè
come si sente la persona alla quale ho
dato di non lo so di ciccione o
accaldato di idiota ho dato di scemo
quello che volete voi
giusto per fare un piccolo florilegio di
parole così e poi ho fatto un'altra
considerazione essendo arrivata la
veneranda età di 40 anni che
effettivamente stare li davanti ai
social a perdere tempo alla ricerca
della risposta più cattiva più
annichilente eccetera eccetera ragazzi
fa venire le rughe perché 1 st così
proprio questa faccia no vado cerco sul
dizionario la parola peggiore marrano
fellone giusto per non usare sempre
quelle parole così comuni e quindi ha
detto veramente io voglio invecchiare
così con questa grossa ruga verticale
fra gli occhi eto'o forse no forse a 40
anni è giunto il momento di smettere con
quella roba
e allora ho pensato io che cosa posso
fare
oggi va molto di moda dire signora mia
che tempi stiamo vivendo i social ci
hanno rovinato
diamo il peggio di noi on line gli altri
devono fare qualcosa
facebook deve far sì che non circolino
certe cose
google deve far sì che gli altri allora
io vorrei un attimo cambiare prospettiva
io e quando dico io dico tutti cioè
ognuno di noi nel suo piccolo nel suo
singolo che cosa può fare e mi sono data
una serie di risposte
la prima ovviamente viene dalla mia
esperienza di linguista la lingua è di
tutti non è di qualcun altro non sono
gli altri che la stanno rovinando
sono i social che la stanno rovinando
gli unici responsabili della salute
della nostra lingua siamo noi parlanti e
quindi questo è un fortissimo invito a
rimetterci tutti al centro dell'atto
comunicativo cioè io persona singola
sono responsabile delle cose che dico
sono responsabile di scegliere la parola
giusta posso anzi trovarci un gusto il
gusto della parola giusta perché le
parole giuste hanno un gusto migliore
delle parole sbagliate e sfatiamo un
altro mito internet non è cattiva
internet contiene esattamente quello che
ci mettiamo dentro per cui se ci trovo
cose brutte è perché qualcuno ce le ha
messe e inviterei anzi tutti a chiedersi
se avete mai voi inserito delle cose in
internet che in realtà ad altri non
farebbero mai che non avrebbero fatto
piacere perché alla fine queste sono
cose che facciamo tutti con un po di
leggerezza allora esattamente come io
non vado in giro buttando le cartacce in
terra e non è che non lo faccio solo
quando gli altri mi vedono ma in
generale no è una specie di come si può
dire tratto che ci contraddistingue io
non butto le cartacce in terra perché
beh perché sono un ecologista
ecco allo stesso modo non vado online a
buttare cartacce comunicative perché
alla fine le parole sbagliate quelle che
fanno male sono proprio come delle
cartacce spesso usa questo paragone per
descrivere il rapporto fra noi utenti e
la rete noi siamo come dei neopatentati
che guidano una ferrari internet e alla
ferrari ci dà delle grandissime
possibilità solo una domanda vi viene
chiesto come si chiama il camion che
porta le automobili senza internet è una
è una domanda alla quale è molto
difficile dare risposta dovete andare da
qualcuno che per lavoro a che fare con i
camion che trasportano automobili si
sarebbe come avremmo potuto fare prima
di internet appunto un processo lungo e
difficile per arrivare alla risposta
giusta
adesso lo potete fare imprese con di
andate su google di citate camion
trasportatore automobili e trovate
subito
risposta che ovviamente molti di voi
sanno ma non la spoiler chiamo va bene
quindi ognuno se la può andare a vedere
per i cavoli suoi
quindi internet cita delle grandissime
possibilità ma noi è come se avessimo la
patente da poco quindi i danni grossi
non li facciamo perché siamo cattivi noi
sa è cattiva la macchina ma sapete che
se avete la patente da poco e prendete
una ferrari qualche problemino lo
potreste avere ergo dobbiamo imparare a
stare in questa nuova situazione di chi
per connessione ad esempio anche
l'ultima persona oggi è come se fosse un
piccolo vip
ognuno di noi ha una parte pubblica
volente o nolente che deve oggi imparare
a gestire per cui non posso più mettere
foto online con la nonchalance con cui
lo faceva una volta
perché in realtà anch'io nel mio piccolo
sono un personaggio pubblico e gli altri
vedranno delle cose di me patente
tornando alla lingua non so se ci avete
mai riflettuto in questi termini ma
siamo gli unici animali che esistono su
questo pianeta che hanno la possibilità
di usare uno strumento così evoluto come
la lingua eppure la diamo per scontata
soprattutto quando si parla della nostra
madre lingua in questo caso
dell'italiano
vabbè ce l'abbiamo dalla nascita no è
una specie di accessorio che sta lì e
invece la lingua è anche il nostro atto
di identità cioè ogni volta che noi
scegliamo di usare una parola rispetto a
un'altra
quello dice qualcosa di noi se io scelgo
di usare nero o afroamericano o
ognuna di queste scelte dice qualcosa di
me di quello che penso e di quello che
voglio che gli altri vedano di me
la lingua è un atto costante di identità
ancora più dell'abbigliamento ancora più
della capigliatura ogni volta che apro
bocca io dico delle cose di me questa è
la rilevanza della lingua quindi siamo
quello che scegliamo di dire perché
nessuno ci punta una pistola alla tempia
quando facciamo una nostra singola
scelta linguistica ma tutti noi abbiamo
questa grandissima libertà questo enorme
potere
di pensare di più alle parole che
scegliamo di dire e poi ricordiamo che
non esistono persone in assoluto buone
in assoluto cattive in assoluto
intelligente o in assoluto sceme
esistono le persone e le persone hanno
degli aspetti positivi e degli aspetti
negativi e tutti noi siamo persone
quindi smettiamola di pensare alla gente
come se fosse il problema di qualcun
altro
la nell'ottica di questo percorso io ho
fatto fa faccio parte dei degli
estensori di questo manifesto della
comunicazione in uno stile il manifesto
nasce più o meno un anno fa trieste e
nasce dal brain storming no qui
dall'unione da una tempesta di cervelli
di tantissimi cervelli più di 200
persone hanno lavorato su questo
manifesto ognuno facendo delle proposte
di principi che gli sembravano
importanti per darsi una regolata non
per dare una regolata agli altri badate
bene ma ognuno di noi per pensare un
secondo di più a quello che fa online
con le parole
vedrete che sono dieci principi
piuttosto semplici tanto semplici che
per alcuni sono anche troppo buonisti
dove buonismo viene usato come un'offesa
ma io non lo trovo vero questo io trovo
che sia dei principi molto basilari e a
volte c'è bisogno di dire le cose ovvie
di veder le scritte e in particolare ci
sono due principi che sono quelli che io
amo di più mettiamola così
il primo è virtuale e reale cioè se noi
smettiamo di pensare nella prospettiva
che quello che facciamo online è diverso
è separato da quello che facciamo della
vita reale
ecco che improvvisamente facciamo meno
danni cioè io mi comporto online
esattamente come mi comporto nella mia
vita reale e poi l'ultimo una regola
d'oro non c'è bisogno di avere sempre
un'opinione da dire
si può scegliere il silenzio uno dei
modi migliori di costruirsi un
autorevolezza online la famosa
reputation oggi si usa questo termine
inglese è anche quella di non parlare a
sproposito
io intervengo solo quando ho delle
opinioni che si basano su qualcosa che
ho studiato
intervengo quando so di cosa sta
parlando non intervengo a vanvera
il silenzio modo fortissimo di
comunicare
ricordate lo è finita qui
no un anno fa è nato il manifesto oggi
recentemente è stato fatto il manifesto
per le pubbliche amministrazioni che
potete immaginare ne hanno un gran
bisogno è stato fatto un manifesto per
la politica
all'uopo vista la situazione attuale è
il manifesto anche è stato tradotto in
11 lingue
a dimostrazione del fatto che c'è una
richiesta in questo senso cioè ci si
sente il bisogno di ragionare su dei
principi che apparentemente sono
basilari banali secondo alcuni ma non
nasciamo tutti i comunicatori c'è
bisogno di riflettere c'è bisogno di
fare esercizio avendo quella patente di
stare online
quindi cerchiamo di andare verso
l'infinito e oltre insomma molti di voi
conosceranno questa citazione coltissima
buzz lightyear esatto
e poi volevo ricordare un ultima cosa
allora dopo avere a lungo riflettuto su
una citazione filosofica pregno di
contenuto così per chiudere questa mia
presentazione alla fine ha avuto
un'illuminazione non è una citazione è
una cosa che penso allora da una parte
noi siamo animali e gli animali si
ribellano hanno la possibilità di
ribellarsi però agli esseri umani fanno
una cosa molto più avanzata perché gli
esseri umani o per ribellarsi possono
fare le rivoluzioni e quindi nel suo
piccolo parole ostili a una piccola
rivoluzione
grazie
[Applauso]